now starting off i'd like to put some
information out for voters to help them
in trying to track their ballot there
are two systems in place one is being
sponsored by the secretary of state
ballot tracks so any voter who's trying
to track
information on the status of their
ballot through ballot tracks should
really put that question through the
secretary of state's office
my staff isn't capable of answering any
questions related to ballot tracks we do
not use it
it's a secretary of state who does in my
system on the website clarkcountymd.gov
forward slash vote
we have registered voter services and in
registered voter services our voters can
check to see the status of their ballot
as far as it being received by my office
all voters should be aware that
vote history will not be posted until
after the canvas
so if you're looking on the secretary of
state site to see if your vote was
posted as voted
you will not see that information that
information is not posted until after
the election
now i'm going to go through a series of
information here and then we're going to
give you an opportunity to ask questions
i have a change from yesterday the
expected turnout
that i reported yesterday was incorrect
the fifty one thousand votes that i
reported would be
available today is actually a little
over thirty thousand
and here's the reason why when we
process
ballots on the counting board our
tracking mechanism changed from precinct
based ballots
to page numbers for the first time in
clark county the ballot is so large that
our ballot is actually two pages long
and so they have to track that when we
scan
ballots so that we can verify that the
count
on those pages is correct my staffer
inadvertently
and mistakenly reported to me that there
were fifty one thousand precinct ballots
to count yesterday
and in actuality it was fifty one
thousand pages
so that explains why when you saw the
updates today
you only saw thirty thousand instead of
the 51.
however the universe of ballots that i
communicated yesterday is still accurate
the only thing you need to do is take it
down approximately 20
500 from the 51 to the 30 000 but the
sixty three thousand ballots that i
reported yesterday
are in the state in the system in
various stages so those will still
expected to be report
reported beginning today
we will begin to re report our results
two times a day so you've already seen
the update for this morning
in the afternoon we will be putting up a
fresh report
on the mail ballots that have been read
into the system sometime before four
o'clock
we're required to report to the
secretary of state first
once they've indicated to us that
they've received it and it's verified
we'll be able to post on our end so
rather than giving a specific time i'll
just tell you that it'll be some time
before 4 pm
now one more time i'd like to go through
the ballots that are separate from that
universe that i reported
we still have the provisional ballots
all of our laptops from election day
have been downloaded
so all of that information is available
to my staff today we will start in
earnest reviewing provisional ballots
there are sixty thousand of those to go
through um
in in various categories now i want to
remind you that
we have to coordinate with the secretary
of state because again we are not a top
down registration state we work from the
bottom up so all 17 counties have to
report to the secretary
they still have not given me the
instructions i know that they're on the
way
but at some point they'll let us know
when to send our report up and that
will be the tool that they use to match
against the other 16 counties in nevada
to make sure that nobody's
duplicated a vote in one county to the
next because we want to prevent that
once we do that we can begin to release
the provisional ballots
into count however that won't happen
until the secretary of state
verifies that report a reminder that
the id required voters their deadline is
today
at 5 pm for those who are required to
provide an id
that has to be sent to us by 5 pm today
we have a cure line available at
702-455-6552
where we have staff available to assist
those
individuals was getting that into us
the u.s mail update for this morning
we receive 241 ballots in today's mail
that will be added to that number that
i'm calling my my universe of ballots to
be counted
it's looking pretty clear that the
number of ballots is going to continue
to go down
however i wanted to ensure the general
public we have been working very close
with our regional supervisor
at the u's postal service and they're
doing an excellent job of reviewing all
of the post stations here
in clark county in fact they have them
sweeping regularly more than once on a
daily basis
and if they identify anything that needs
to be delivered to the office they get
it to our office
within three to four hours it doesn't
even go to the process
of uh having it set up for us to pick up
they're physically delivering those so
we appreciate their effort uh they're
making sure just as we are that we're
counting every ballot that's eligible to
be counted so our thanks to the u.s
postal service locally
the cure process is another group of
ballots that we need to process
they have until thursday the 12th of
november to cure that
my staff will not leave this facility
until we've counted all of those ballots
that have
been identified ab4 was very clear in
the legislative
legislative special session that we have
to have all ballots counted
by november 12th and with that i'll open
it
up for questions remember you need to be
at the mic
good morning right there thank you right
there
whoever you do yeah yeah good afternoon
uh good morning uh mr registrar
can you tell us the number of ballots
that you expect in this
afternoon dump so you said the 31 000
was the total for this morning
it won't be or thirty thousand well it's
not thirty one thousand i'm sorry yeah
thirty can you so let's just be clear
here 30 0403 was the increase 30 000 403
this afternoon before 4 pm how many do
you expect because we're starting to
dump two reports a day i can't
accurately give you that number
the only thing that i can tell you is
the numbers that i reported as my
universe
universal ballots that need to be
counted is still accurate so we know
we're going to need to get
approximately 63 000 ballots into the
system so still
63 guys i'm sorry 63 000 over the next
couple of days will be entered into the
system okay so 63 000
still outstanding uh 30 000 this morning
and tbd you don't know how many this
afternoon no i can't give you that that
number accurately because we've changed
to a two report in the day and so
they're going to work as hard as they
can
they're being very efficient back there
in the way that they count through the
iccs so
we'll get as many in as we can and then
we'll continue to read after that report
and there will be another report
tomorrow morning
with whatever we read this afternoon and
evening okay thanks this is my colleague
jolyn kent
thank you jacob i know we talked about
the pace yesterday but
there's increasing pressure on your
county to count
faster you have the capacity to count 71
000 ballots a day
why not process that number joe as i
described yesterday
the process is very deliberate in the
way we process here so through the
agilis which is our
mail ballot processing system that's the
first step
that agilis machine will verify
signatures
and then those that aren't verified as a
match that has to go to a
manual physical process and there are
two steps in that process
where we have staff running through
those we have to run those through those
two steps
and then at that point it moves to our
counting board our counting board then
works to verify those records
to make sure that our batches are
matching and that we're reconciling
correctly
and they go through the process of
separating the ballots and getting them
over here for us to count
so there's no speeding up that process
as i indicated yesterday we're going to
continue to count and make sure that
we're being accurate
we're anticipating and hoping that with
the number of ballots that we see
now we should hopefully be ready to have
a final count on the majority of mail
ballots
by sunday at some time by sunday and
what's your message to all of the people
out there watching clark county
who say come on let's go hurry it up
i think i mentioned yesterday that our
priority here is to make sure that we're
accurate in what we're doing
so we're not interested in moving as
fast as we can we want to be accurate
we're very fortunate at this point that
we've had staff working for many days
and they're very efficient in what
they're doing
so we're confident that the work is
being done accurately
and that's what our our main goal is
thank you
can you talk about the circumstances
that require
an id what are those id required ballots
because there's quite a lot of them and
how are those different from the other
ballots that need to be cured
the easiest explanation for the cure is
that those voters who send back a mail
ballot that
is not signed at all or that has a
signature that doesn't match
all of our history of signatures in the
system they enter into the cure process
that's statutorily required and we have
to mail a notice to the voter
and if the voter has given us an email
or a phone number we also contact them
through an automated message with that
as well those are the cures
the id required can come from many
different areas
in the state of nevada now we've
implemented same-day registration
the online registrations that go through
the secretary of state's nova site
state law requires that those voters
show up to vote
our system indicates that they
registered online they're required to
show an id
so they showed up to vote in person
either early voting or election day
and they didn't have their id so they're
required to provide that by today at 5
pm in order for those votes to count
we also have a large number of mail
ballots everybody's well aware that
we've sent a mail ballot to all active
registered voters in clark county
so there's not as much familiarity from
the general public on what to do with
the mail
ballot we very clearly indicate on the
mailing envelope
those voters who need to send in an id
because in their registration
we were unable to match correctly with
our check with dmv
or social security and so they must
provide an idea another order for us to
hold up the integrity of the process
so in those two groups that's the
majority of the ids that are required
next question joe a new federal lawsuit
has
uh the from the trump campaign has
requested that
the use of the agility system be stopped
completely
and that instead all ballots be uh
verified by hand the signatures be
verified by hand
what would that do to the counting
process if your access to agilis is
lost if they were successful i will
mention that that's already been heard
in court and that request was denied so
we're hoping that that stays consistent
however if we were unable to use the
agilis machine
we're working hard to get everything
through now so we won't have to worry
about that but that would slow down our
process tremendously
because we've geared our process to
count on the agility machine
so we'd have to go completely manual at
that point
and so yeah it would slow down our
process without a doubt next question
um so the nevada gop has confirmed this
morning that they have dropped
or have come into an agreement with the
county on the lawsuit that was issued
yesterday can you comment on that
your question was that the nevada gop
has
they've confirmed that the campaign has
dropped the federal lawsuit that was
issued out yesterday
well i may be incorrect but i think
they've reinstituted that so i'm
i don't know if you have the current
information from last week
hi uh mr gloria just to be completely
clear yesterday you said there were
63 262 outstanding ballots correct
today we have those 30 000 uh that new
batch and then
so the outstanding ballots would be
around 30
no sir no that's 33 000. you're confu
you're confusing the two numbers that i
reported so yesterday
what i stated that was that we expected
to see 51 000
ballots read yesterday correct because
the page numbers were reported
mistakenly instead of the precinct count
that count went down from 51 to 30.
right
so the 63 let me finish so the 63 000
are still in process and need to be
counted
so bottom line i mean outstanding
ballots right now
out of that number of 63 000 still 63
24 hours later that is correct
63 000.
i wish you'd come to the mic so that i
could hear you well anybody who wants to
answer
ask a question please take the time to
come up front we're going to go right
here
uh mr gloria you mentioned receiving i
think 241
ballots to their postal service today
how many
do you know have you received since
election day
oh i'm sorry i'm not prepared for the
entire total
i have today's yesterday in yesterday's
press conference i believe that i
mentioned that
oh no i do have it here so for election
day and wednesday the mail
intake was 4208.
next question good morning in the
lawsuit that was filed today
in addition to acting for the agilis
machine to be stopped again they also
allege that there were 3 000 plus
instances of ineligible ballots which
were cast
do you have any evidence of that that
has been given to you and do you have
any knowledge of those 3 000 ballots
that the nevada gop is alleging they
provided us with a list
we'll have to begin to look through that
however
their lawsuit is based on something that
happens regularly
you don't have to live here in order to
be eligible to vote here
this is a military town we have nellis
air force base
we also have several students that
travel outside of the state
to go to school those folks are eligible
to vote
here in nevada we also have
local representatives congressmen
senators they're up in washington
working but they live here they vote
here so
we'll have to look through those numbers
but it's not out of the ordinary at all
for somebody not to live here
but be eligible to vote here so we will
look at that
and we'll review it you need the mic
sorry just to quickly follow up on the
number of military ballots
um sort of related but separate you had
also said the other day that's part of
what you're going through in addition to
provisional ballots
how many outstanding military ballots
are there do you know
the military ballots have been read into
the system
hi sorry can i just clarify the math
yes total number of outstanding ballots
including the provisional
is what the provisional are beginning to
be looked at in earnest today because
all of the data
just get rid of the number i'll answer
the question the provisional account
will be 60
000. okay mail ballots that still need
to be run through the system and are
expected to run through for count
it's 63 262 approximately
okay and are we subtracting 30 000 from
that 63 or not
no so none of the 63 have been counted
no sir so where where's that 30 000
number that you mentioned this when you
can you report today check the website
clarkcountynv.gov forward slash vote
okay but so that why doesn't why isn't
that coming out of the 63
because i mentioned yesterday that we
had 51 000 ballots to count that was
incorrect
because i was given the number of pages
right 30
000 is in the system and reported this
morning
so 30 000 so there's still sixty three
thousand and the sixty thousand beyond
the thirty thousand
don't mumble so thirty thousand were
counted yesterday
that is correct there are still sixty
three thousand mail ballots
to be counted that is correct and sixty
thousand provisional
those won't all be counted don't won't
meet the requirements for them to be
registered but they need to be reviewed
okay and what are the hours of the
counting
the hours of whatsapp what are the hours
that your people are working on the
count
i can have a member of my staff make
that available and how many people
roughly are involved in this process at
least 300
really okay thank you you're welcome
mr gloria at the risk of going back to
math
from 51 000 we reported 30
000 does that leave 21 000 no sir
okay and i i started out by explaining
that
the numbers i reported yesterday were
incorrect and i gave an explanation as
to why
our staff at the accounting board
incorrectly mistakenly
provided me with the number of pages
that they sent over to be read however
that was not the number of precinct
ballots
every ballot in nevada that sent to the
voters represents two pages
and so there were actually only 30 000
ballots that were read so i've corrected
that
and explained to you why that occurred
so
the 63 262
and no more than that no there could be
more
we still have cures we still have ids
that need to be
and we still have provisionals and then
those are all outside of the universe
that i've been reporting
and then the final are the 241
that you said you received by the minute
that's today sir including date through
the mail
and that will continue to be received
through next tuesday are they included
in 63 260 no sure
those are outside of that and thank you
joe i think the most com all of the
confusion lays in
why hasn't that number gone down what
happened between
not with the misreporting of the number
but then why hasn't the number of
ballots that were counted
gone down
the between 000 as we speak they're
reading them into the system some of
those so it is going down
it's just not in this morning's report
this morning's report only goes up to
the end of day
yesterday and so they're now processing
those
we'll have some numbers to report just
before four o'clock on that 63 000
and we'll continue to do so until we're
finished with all of those ballots
joe right here so um and i'm staying on
the math
sorry i'm alright here staying on the
mat so is it 63
000 and then the additional 60 000
provisional ballots does that mean is it
a
123 000 or am i confusing
60 000 provisional ballots need to be
reviewed
they won't all be eligible to be cast
but yes they
still need to be reviewed but i can't
tell you how many of those will be moved
forward to count
um the gop has uh asked the department
of justice to
investigate um some of
and i'm just wondering if you received
the uh the list
of the voters names that they're looking
into
and what's your i need you to be more
specific with what list you're referring
to is it in the lawsuit that they
recently provided or their list that i'm
not aware of
uh regarding the the they're asking the
department of justice to investigate
i don't know anything about that i can't
answer that question
a deal was struck allowing more verse
to come in can you go into detail out
that deal
i can't hear you there was a deal uh
observers have any
information regarding that deal as part
of that lawsuit from last week
that was cleared i believe that we
agreed to provide some more observer
locations in our accounting boards
location okay but they've rescinded that
so i
i'll have to talk to my civil d.a
okay i'm sorry i wasn't a good math
student
i'm trying to get like a final tally
what we're expecting so there's 63
000 provisional ballots that need to be
reviewed correct
correct in addition to that there's
another 60 000 ballots that aren't
provisional
that need to be that are provisional but
there's those won't all be qualified to
vote they need to be reviewed i
understand about ballpark
for me what so are we looking at 120 000
ballots need to be reviewed and are
audited and counted or is it
63 000 and change that let's make sure
and clarify that there's two types of
tally types that you're referring to
provisional is electronic those are
voted on the in-person voting machines
the mail that i'm referring to is
separate that's a different tally type
so that's the sixty three thousand so
there's some electronic ballots that
were voted
provisionally that i'll need to be
reviewed they're held in queue
so they won't actually be counted until
my staff
correctly identifies whether they were
eligible to be counted
so that's separate but there's 60 000
plus the 63 thousand
that i'm referring to so there's roughly
so
just clarify for me we're looking at
roughly 123 000
ballots that still have to be reviewed
audited and or accounted is that correct
that's what i'm reporting but you need
to keep in mind that we still have no id
voters that can show up we still have
cures that can still show up and we also
have u.s mail
okay so i'd love to make it easier for
you but it's a complicated process
i think we all appreciate what i'm
trying to do is give you the numbers on
the large
sure i think we all need a ballpark to
be able to actually report we don't want
to say 60 000.
i think it's fair to say that the 63 000
mail and the 60 000 provisional
are the largest chunks left that we have
to remember and and
again not to misquote you i hope i
didn't misunderstand but you anticipate
having
those completed counted by sunday is
that exactly what i said
the mail so we're hoping to have the
mail done by sunday if all goes well and
that number again is what i'm sorry
60 000. 63 000 okay
okay so you're anticipating 63 more
thousand ballots being completed counted
by
sunday and then there's the other 60 000
that's right to be reviewed which we'll
go through next week
you've got it thank you next question
can i change away from math for a moment
how's your security we've been standing
we've been reading about
a situation in philadelphia have there
been any credible threats to your
knowledge
to the voting uh count or your
facilities
in and around las vegas i i really can't
release any of the reports on anything
that would be credible
we keep that within our law enforcement
group and they are dealing with it
i can tell you that they're monitoring
social media for any threatening type of
messages
as you can see when you came today we we
have a a relatively large force of law
enforcement plus our county
uh security that's here in place um
so i i feel that the response has been
excellent
from the community from the
commissioners who called to make sure
that we had
um that support um
but i i it's just troubling for my
employees
i have employees who are nervous leaving
the building um
and right rightfully so they work late
into the night
so we strongly encourage all of them not
to leave by themselves
they can also request an escort from our
security people or law enforcement
so we're doing everything we can to
protect our employees and i
i think the response from local law
enforcement and the assistant we
received from our
county commission has helped to make
sure that that happens so
we're doing the best we can folks we
have two more questions
how about yesterday that you uh plus
these numbers
to yesterday we have 40 44 000
id requiring ballots and 2 100 ballots
in the cube process
is the same number today
you know what i was looking for you can
you do that again i didn't see you i'm
sorry she just said again
yesterday we're talking about four
thousand four hundred uh
forty four thousand id requirements
ballot and today and yesterday we have
two thousand one hundred ballots in the
cure process
is the same number today i would have to
run that report for you
i did not come prepared with those
numbers but those were accurate
yesterday
as i mentioned outside of that universe
of numbers the mail
and the provisional we still have the id
required we still have the cures
and we still have the u.s mail that
still has to come through
so yes the answer to your question is
those people are still
eligible if they bring us an id to have
their ballot counted
one more question where is it last
question right here
last question right here joe can you
talk about the settlement
that came with the lawsuit going into
last week the reason behind it and just
anything moving forward
uh brief i can just briefly say that the
republicans had communicated to our
legal team
that they were willing to drop their
suit if we would provide
some additional locations in an area
that we were providing it as a courtesy
again i remind all of you the only thing
that is statutorily required for
observers is we allow them to watch us
cat count and tally votes which is
happening right behind us
everything else that we've provided is
provided as a courtesy we're not
we're not required by law to do so but
that that's what the settlement dealt
with but
they've rescinded it so i'll have to
talk to my civil d.a to see
where we're at with that thank you all
very much we'll see you tomorrow
at 10 a.m